مرحبا وسهلا كل من محله هذا العالم وسعبت
انا واحلى زينا المباني حققنا الاماني عيش
اللحظه معنا ودندني ودان داني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاغنيه بمناسبه كاس العالم
ماهر زين ومن اخراج المخرج السعودي
الحلم السمانه وعلى الوعد جانا يلا نلعب
سويه
وهيا والله يعني هو كل فنان يتمنى انه
يكون لهم مشاركه في حدا عالمي نفس كاس
العالم خصوصا اذا صار كاس العالم في بلد
عربي وبلد خليجي
فانا كان عندي هذا
يعني هذا الفكره انه ودي اسوي ماهر ايضا
كان عنده هذه الفكره لكاس العالم
واحنا نعرف بعض من زمان
وجمهوره وجمهوري يطالبون من زمان ونعملته
حسين مناسبه كاس العالم مناسبه جيده نعمل
همم هذا التعاون صارت في فرصه همم قبل
افتتاح تقريبا ثلاث اسابيع بسرعه عشان
كلنا فريق الكتاب الاغنيه والتوزيع
الموسيقي والمخرجين
صورناها في الدوحه خلال الفتره 3 ايام على
ثلاث ايام
وانطلقت الحمد لله في اي فنان لم يشتغل
على الاغنيه المفروض هو يكون مقتنع فيها
لكن دائما في هذا يعني انت مش متاكد ان
الناس حتسمعها بنفس الطريقه التي تسمعها
فانت تتوقعنا لها النجاح بس ما اتوقع انه
الى هذا الحديث يعني احنا الي اليوم
اعتقد وصلت 17 او 18 مليون وصالح مش
متاكده همم خلال فتره اسبوع
فهل هذا انا كنت اتوقع للامانه لا لكن
سعيد جدا جدا بصراحه بتقبل الناس الاغنيه
وتفاعلهم معها
اكيد اي فنان يتمنى يكون لها حضور ومشاركه
في حدث عالمي المسؤوليه كفنان عربي اشعر
ان هذه فرصه ان اظهر ثقافتنا العربيه
موسيقتنا العربيه هويتنا حتى رقصاتنا
ملابسنا في هذا العمل هذه فرصه ان احنا
نوري العالم كله
الثقافه العربيه
فيعني هذا كان بدافع الرئيسي بالنسبه لهذا
العمل
واتمنى اني قدرنا انا وزميلي الفنان ماهر
زين
تحدي الاكبر كان بالنسبه للوقت الضيق
الفرصه جاءت قبل ثلاث اسابيع من الافتتاح
هذا كانت التحدي الاكبر همم
يعني في تجربه سويتها لاول مره ان الكلمات
العربيه اكتبها شاعران كان واحد منهم اخوي
طلال الخضر والشاعر احمد قطر امم هذه
النمط في كتابه الاغاني دارج في الاغاني
الانجليزيه والاجنبيه نكون في اكثر من
كاتب في الاغاني العربيه مش متعودين على
الكولابريشن لكن جربناها كان في صعوبه لكن
الحمد لله نتيجه كانت جدا مرضيه بالنسبه
لكل فريق الكتاب
وهممين يعني
السلام عليكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بالانتهاء من التصوير حضور مباراه
الافتتاح
حضرت مباراه السعوديه والمكسيك
كنا نتمنى لهم الفوز لكن عنده اداء جميل
وحضرت مباراه المغرب وكندا هذا اللي كانت
يعني
لكل الوطن العربي لكل احتفل
بفوز المغرب وتاهل للدور
ايه المشكله توقعات غير الامنيات يعني
الامنيات المغرب اذا مش المغرب الارجنتين
ودي لنا ميسي يتوج يتوج يعني
بما ياخذ كاس العالم النشاطات يعني بدات
طبعا في اغنيه تحيه والفيديو كليب امس كان
عندي الحفل في المسرح المفتوح في كتاره
المسافرين الاردن للي همم لحضور بنشوف
مباراه في فانزون في مخيم اللاجئين في
الزعتري همم عاملين مثل فانزونز في مخيمات
اللاجئين راح نروح نحضر مباراه معهم راح
نغني معاهم اغنيه كاس العالم
بعدها راح اروح الى اسبانيا هيكون عندي
جوله فنيه في برشلونه مدريد همم بعدها
راجع قطر
الرساله هي بالدرجه الاولى احتفاليه انت
قاعد تحتفل بكاس العالم هذه المناسبه تجمع
الكل كل الشعوب ومن هنا تاتي للقيام
الاخرى يعني قيمه الوحده قيمه السلام امم
يعني والقيم الثانيه اللي قلنا بنبرد نبرز
موسيقى العربيه وثقافتنا العربيه وهويتنا